[Music]
whenever I hear there is a list of who
are the hottest redheads naturally I'm
like I gotta check this it's not funny
I'm never on it you are always at the
top of the list and I'm just curious
because I just thought like okay that
makes perfect sense then I found out
that you decided to become a redhead
when you were quite young
yeah I'm faking it it's true and I
somehow squeak in on those lists yeah
I'm an imposter
yeah but yeah I started doing it when I
was about 10 years old my mom let me put
some hair color on and and I came to
school the next day and my teacher is
wrong with you acclaiming hair you know
what's so interesting I bring this up
because as a kid and I think it's true
of a lot of kids we don't want to be
like I made my peace with it but I was a
kid I did not want to be a redhead I
hated that I was a redhead so it's very
strange for me to think of someone
saying I desperately want to be a
redhead I think I was already getting
picked on so it's like bring it on but
you thought okay but that was brave to
say I'm gonna go with this choice and do
it as a kid I think it was just I
everyone that I liked on TV was a
redhead and all the people that I
gravitated towards it was an Margaret
and it was ginger from Gilligan's Island
and there's that redhead on scooby-doo
right and I just liked all the redheads
so a shaggy shaggy Oh
they just revealed I have a crush on
shaggy Scooby Snacks